Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Squarespace launching their new campaign.
Make your next move, make your next move and set new goals for this year.
Lock down your next move idea with a unique domain and create a website to
launch today by using offer code Radiolab for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website.
Make your next move with Squarespace more@squarespace.com
hey, wait, you're looking okay.
[inaudible]
you are listening to radio lab radio. W.
N y. S. T. E. N n.
P. R. Hello. We're going to start this show today.
Hey Mary with Mary Roach. Hey Tim here. Hi Tim. Hey,
let me see if I can.
Mary is one of our favorite authors mostly past cause she kinda writes about
stuff that's specific, yucky gross. I'm the kind of person who, if I'm,
I'm I find myself in an operating room for whatever I'm reporting on in that
kind of a person where they, there'll be like Ms. Roach, you need to step back.
Your head is actually inside the body of family and a for her latest book called
Gulp. She got really, really into and inside cows. Yeah.
The fist related cows that the agricultural schools have and what's a Fistula
Fistula is a irregular anatomical passageway and officiated cow in this case has
a whole opening right in its size so that you can actually stick your hand into
its side and reach all the way down to the stomach. This is the living cow,
right? It's a moving live cow. And you've done this. Yeah, it was um,
it was this amazing, uh, because really the, you know,
a cow is about [inaudible] at the University of California Davis. You're just,
you're standing there and sort of normally, and I,
and for some reason I've worn a skirt and kitten heels and I'm,
my hosts are wearing manure in crusted muck boots and there is a source of great
entertainment that I'm here
and it's packed really tightly. You had to really work your arm.
The Guy I was with Ed to Peters and he's like, no, keep going, keep going.
I'm like, I don't know. And I'm not sure really go further in or, yeah,
keep going, keep going. And I'm literally up to my shoulder inside this cow.
I still want to do that. Where are you guys? We're in New York. Yeah,
I know where there's one out there. I can get you a fist deflated cat.
Walk them down towards the barn and I'll go get the group. All right. Yeah.
I didn't actually get to do it unfortunately, but we sent our producer,
Tim Howard and Tim out to Rutgers university and closure where a bunch of high
schoolers had come to see how lily, lily, lily the fist elated cow.
Okay, let's give it a go. I'm gonna pop the court. Did he say Cork?
Yeah. You have to uncork the whole on the couch. All the steam coming out.
Ready. All right.
This is a Tim reaching his hand in for straight across the top to the far side.
Okay. Oh my God.
Powerful in there. Yeah. Oh God. I mean,
I was a little worried it was going to break my hand. [inaudible] pressure.
Yeah. It's a very muscular organism, squeezing my arms,
mixing and I can feel the side of the stomach pushing against squeezing and
contracting and squeezing, cruelly squeezing it.
It's groping you back
stuck. I'm just going to try to go a little bit,
little bit deeper and it's hot. It's steamed. It's bubbly and physical.
It's very, Huh.
She is so calm right now. I can't believe it.
The cows board,
and I've got this look on my face like I've seen God or something.
[inaudible]
Mary says that for all her times in morgues and in all the places she's been,
this one, this one was was was really different.
It was the expression I was wearing. I'm sure I've never had cause to use
[inaudible]
and here's why.
If you think about the stomach is a center of magical transformation.
That is Fred Kaufman who wrote a whole book about the stomach.
You take something outside of your body,
you put it in your body and it turns into you.
So it's like this conduit between what's outside you and what's inside.
The other thing that's weird is that the human body is a Taurus. We're donuts.
We've got a whole going through the middle of us all the way through us. So,
which seems to be inside us with seems to be inside our stomach actually is
always outside of us.
Whoa.
Oh this is getting so deep. You don't like the dark? No, I,
I mean it's crazy. I can go. I'll,
I'll know cause I was thinking we could start that way cause that's what we're
kind of doing this out.
We're going to take this thing that's deep inside us and turn it inside out.
Yeah. I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab and today guts that mystery them lies between our mouth and our
butt.
We are these sacks of guts when we won any skeletons and we walk around and we
never even see them. We don't.
And for centuries nobody really knew what's going on in there.
But then something happened that uh, opened up a window. Yeah.
Do you want to start here? What I heard at the beginning of it? Yeah. Let's,
once upon a time it, okay. So once upon a time it all begins and witnesses,
they first met in 1822.
Once upon a time in 1822 there was a guy named William Beaumont.
William Beaumont is a farm boy from Lebanon, Connecticut, uh,
five brothers and six sisters, and William clearly is the smart one.
He was the one one with big dreams. So at an early age,
you leaves home and gets himself a job as a doctor,
an army doctor up north at Fort Mackinac, which is this,
it's a trading post, basically [inaudible].
He has a little doctor's office at the top of this hill and at the bottom
there's a general store for a, for traders who would come in from Canada.
Super Hardy. Dude's like, it's cold up there,
and they're going out in canoes and they're running with these huge packages of
furs on their backs and big beards. Sure. Yankees, that was all just set up.
Here's the actual story. One day, June 6th, 1822 normal morning,
all the fur traders come in and are unloading and loading and getting their
coffee, salted meat supplies to go out trips and for when all of a sudden
right outside the shop, somebody's gun went off. Somebody calls Beaumont,
Beaumont, dashes out the door, runs down the hill, finds this guy,
this 18 year old kid, really in bad shape.
Woo.
The kids lying on the ground. He's a big guy, muscular,
but he's covered in blood and he has eight hole right below his rib cage,
about the size of the palm of a grown man's hand. Nobody was sure what happened,
but someone's gun had gone off by accident and shot this boy point blank.
His lungs are dripping out. There's blood. This is what Beaumont sees,
but this is what's going on. Seeds. And the other thing Beaumont sees is food
coming out of his stomach. Meat and bread and coffee. Yeah.
These are the remnants of his breakfast spilled out on the ground right in front
of.
You can kind of see the gears turning in Beaumont's head as if he's thinking,
whoa, there it is. Digestion. Inaction,
which was kind of disgusting,
but it was also something of a revelation because in 1822 the stomach was an
area of mystery. Just like today,
we're aware of the brain is an area of mystery and for centuries people believed
that the stomach more broadly, the gut was in a very real way,
the center of our beans. Yes, in Puritan Times,
the bowels are the seat of human sympathy. You know,
like where our deepest feelings come from. If you have bowels for somebody,
that means you sympathize with that. It that something people will say,
absolutely no, we should bring that, turn it back. Yeah, I have bowels.
For you point is medical science was pretty fuzzy on what happens down there.
I mean, they knew it was important, but they had no idea how it worked.
Like how does food become us?
Nobody understood it because they can't see,
you can't directly observe it without opening the person up.
But here was a guy open right up.
But of course go on is a doctor. So he's like, wait, I've got to save this guy.
So he start sewing him up frantically.
Pretty sure this fellow's not gonna make it.
And he was surprised that two days later the guy was alive. Really surprised.
And as the months passed, this kid, St Martin, that was his name,
Alexis Saint Martin, he gets better.
But a year later he still has his hole in his stomach. The hole never closes.
What happened is he grew a fistula. No,
just like the cow we talked about earlier,
except in this case he didn't have a cork where he was wounded.
He had a flap of skin covering the whole, if you want to use,
pull back the flap and look inside.
And we don't know if Beaumont left it that way on purpose.
What we do know is that he sees an opportunity to make the body give up its
secrets. He sees he's got something that nobody else has.
Maybe he even thinks this man could be my ticket out of being a lowly,
a Fort Mackinac doctor.
So Beaumont kind of hires him as a man around his house as a man servant,
you know, he said, all right, it was a charitable thing. I wanted to help him,
you know, cause he couldn't work. And I'm thinking, oh, maybe, maybe not.
And so about a year later, he starts,
he starts his experiments. Oh my Lord. This is straight out of movie.
While reporting this story,
we ended up visiting the rare book room at the New York Academy of Medicine,
which is pretty much the coolest room ever. It's all Mahogany.
And they've got an ancient skull sitting on top of bookshelves,
and the books are hundreds and hundreds of years old. In any case,
the librarian, Arlene Shaner,
showed us around and then put on some white gloves,
disappeared between some stacks and came out with a little purple book.
Beaumont's observations.
Experiment one is on August 1st,
1825 so at 12 o'clock I introduced through the perforation into the stomach,
the following articles of diets. So what he does is he,
he takes different foods, a piece of raw salted fat pork,
some corn beef, you know, like a one inch square of corn beef,
a piece of stale bread,
and he attaches them to a silk string and he inserts them through the artificial
opening into the stomach, into the stomach for an hour.
Then he takes it out like a fishermen. Yeah, yeah. He's fishing,
he's doing stomach fishing and he takes it out and he records, you know,
so it was an hour later how much, uh, was digested,
withdrew and examined them, found the cabbage and bred about half the Justin,
the pieces of meat on this went on for hours,
turned to them into the stomach at 2:00 PM withdrew them again and hours we
turned them into the stomach. Gan for years. Over the next few years,
Beaumont puts anything he can possibly think of into that stomach. Pigs,
feet south, take an hour. Animals, brains spoiled.
Take an hour and 45 minutes. Fresh eggs, hard boiled.
Take three hours and 30 minutes. Soft boiled, take three hours. Fresh eggs,
fried, take three hours and 30 minute fresh eggs roasted.
Take two hours and 15 minutes. Look,
it's just the totality of food in America at that point.
Whipped eggs take an hour and a half.
He's trying everything baked custard and takes two hours and 45 minutes. God,
that goes on for pages.
Alexis St Martin is becoming increasingly irritable about this whole process,
I would imagine.
Because a lot of the times the things that Beaumont went sticking to his stomach
would make him sick, give him a fever, pain in his head, depressed, pulse,
dry skin, coated tongue and numerous.
So in 1825 three years after the cell started,
St Martin finally bolts goes back to Canada, gets married,
even has a few kids.
All the while Beaumont is writing him letters trying to lure him back and he was
offering him, okay, I'll pay for your family. Okay, I'll give you $50 a year.
Okay, I'll give you,
I'll give you 75 I mean we kept and names like I'll throw in the land cause you
know, he's still wanting to know like, all right, fine,
it takes three hours and 15 minutes to digest a carrot oyster soup.
Three and a half hours or soup, whatever. But how does it work?
How does the stomach do it? And eventually because he needs the money.
Alexis St Martin does come back.
Beaumont starts his experiments again in one night while Beaumont is peering
into the boys' stomach.
He gets his answer.
He says he applies a few crumbs of bread to the inner surface of the stomach.
Immediately afterwards, small, sharp papillary became visible.
He saw little pimples form on the wall of the stomach and out of the pimples.
Zuta a clear, transparent liquor out some juice out. Squirt some juice.
[inaudible]
that was it. That's the magic juice. Clear. Almost transparent.
Tasted a little salt dish and acid [inaudible] to the tongue.
Yeah. Tasting.
Lot of tasting went on and then he would collect the stomach acid and see if you
could digest outside the body because there was this theory that the body had
this vital force and that that was necessary for the bodily processes,
including digestion. So if you took the stomach acid out, what would happen?
December 14th,
1829 and 1:00 PM I took one and a half ounces of gastric juice fresh from the
stomach, put into it. 12 grams recently salted beef boiled.
The theory at the time was, oh, it wouldn't work.
You had to have the magical powers of the human body,
but digestion commenced
[inaudible]
in Beaumont, one of his big discoveries was, no, you don't actually,
there are no secret forces of sympathy and excitement driving things.
It's a chemical. That's what it's all about. Now,
Beaumont didn't know it, but that juice he was seeing,
which he called gastric juice,
those are enzymes and what enzymes are are like little chemical scissors.
They break down food so that you can take something in from the outside like
this carrot and absorb. It
comes literally a part of you. The key to the whole thing.
The key to life are enzymes. In a way.
They are the magical force, Justin chemical form. That's it. That's the truth.
He was the first to understand it, the first to see it,
the first to figure out the method of how to prove it and he proved it.
So Beaumont writes a book about this and this book is published in 1833 and he
becomes famous.
People were fascinated by Beaumont's experiments.
He would kind of go on these tours. He's a called over to Yale University,
gets invited to speak in Europe with his, you know, wherever he goes.
He brings his gastric juice and he lets him there on the dude's stomach. Yeah,
yeah. He travels around with it and whenever he could,
he would take Saint Martin with them. St Martin was his PowerPoint, you know,
he's like, I need you man.
I need you on the stage so everybody else can come up and stick their tongue in
your stuff. For William Beaumont, this works out pretty great.
He's thought of as this, you know,
tremendous contributor to the understanding of digestion.
As for Alexis, St Martin, he was a curiosity
[inaudible].
He was a medical curiosity for the rest of his life. The day he dies,
even in death, his body is a hot commodity and his family was very aware of this
[inaudible].
They let his body rot in the sun for three days and then buried him very deeply
and put big rocks over him so he would not be exhumed.
[inaudible]
thanks to Arlene Shaner at the New York Academy of Medicine, and Fred Kaufman,
who wrote a book called a short history of the American stomach,
and a special thanks to Mary Roach, her forthcoming book is called, got it.
Tripped down the elementary canal.
[inaudible].